Hi, everyone.
My name is Sahar Golestani.
I've been working with our
publishers and developers
at Google for three years
trying to understand
what are your needs, what
makes you happy, where
can we as Google, help, and
how to improve our products
to better meet your needs.
In this video, I will dive
into what is Google AdMob
and what does ad
monetizations mean to you.
AdMob is a mobile advertising
company founded back in 2006.
Google saw the
potential of AdMob.
And in November 2010,
we welcomed it happily
to our Google family.
From there, Google has invested
heavily into the product.
In 2012, we added more buyers.
In 2013, we gave
AdMob a facelift
with the new
app-centric interface.
And through continued
investment and development,
AdMob has become a
powerful platform
to monetize, promote, and
analyze app performance.
AdMob brings together
best-in-class technology
in one single platform
so you can gain insights
about your users, drive
more in-app purchases,
and maximize your ad revenue.
No longer will you have to
rely on a combination of tools
or use your precious
development resources
to build your own solution.
Over 650,000 apps
use AdMob, and we
are very proud to have
paid more than one billion
to our developers.
AdMob is the number one platform
to grow your app business.
Our best-in-class
technology enables
AdMob to provide fast
and reliable payment
in local currencies, high
CPMs, and the best fill rates,
while providing an
industry-leading mediation
platform, which all translates
to more dollars for you.
Powered by Google's
ad technology,
AdMob has helped
millions of developers
grow their digital
business for over a decade.
AdMob can be used with all the
top platforms, Android and iOS,
with support for leading
game engines, such as Unity
and Cocos2d-x.
Finally, AdMob's integration
with Google Play services
pushes automatic performance
improvements to Android
without additional SDK changes.
Google AdMob really
cares about your users,
and it ensures it
provides the tools you
need to better understand them.
Analyze your app's
performance from within AdMob
with Google Analytics.
Discover where people
are downloading
your app and the features they
use the most in real time.
Additionally, use
flow visualization
reports to see how people are
navigating through your app
with graphical flow reports.
View the path they
take towards making
a purchase and the point where
they exit the app plus much,
much more.
AdMob allows you to really
maximize your earnings
with our industry
leading ad service.
This includes free
mediation, referred
to as yield management
in the industry,
through enabling
multiple ad networks
to bid on your ad space.
Secondly, it allows you to grow
your in-app purchase revenue.
Thirdly, it allows you to
cross-promote your apps,
and finally, get paid fast while
using this very, easy and free
solution.
My colleague, Joe,
will deep dive
into how to get
started with AdMob
and what are some of the key
features in the next video.
Thanks for watching.
Be sure to check out
our other AdMob videos,
subscribe to our channel, and
visit google.com/admob for more
information.
[MUSIC PLAYING]